[Music]
this QuickStart shows you how to use
cloud build to build a docker image and
push the image to container registry you
will first build the image using a
docker file and then build this same
image using a configuration file before
you begin make sure you have a Google
cloud project selected and then you have
installed and initialized the cloud SDK
begin by running G cloud off login in
the command line to authorize a g-cloud
command line tool to access your project
use g-cloud config set project to
connect the G cloud tool with your
project now we'll create a simple hello
world example in a docker file cloud
build allows you to build a docker image
using a docker file you don't require a
separate build config file first we'll
create a script for our container to
execute called QuickStart Sh next we'll
create a file called docker file finally
in the command line
we'll make sure that QuickStart that SH
is executable in the directory where the
docker file is use the G cloud build
submit command with the tag flag set to
the project name and image name you want
to create if you have not enabled the
cloud build API you will be prompted to
do so now you've just built a docker
image using a docker file and push the
image to container registry let's build
the same image using a cloud build
Yamhill config file in the same
directory that contains QuickStart Sh in
the docker file create a file named
cloud build llamó this build config
instructs cloud build to perform tasks
based on your specifications
after we've built cloud build llamó
we'll use the G cloud build submit
command with the config cloud build
llamo flag to build our image and push
it to container registry once we've
built the image and pushed it to the
container registry we can use the Google
Cloud console to view the build details
on the cloud build page once there you
will see the build history by clicking
on a specific image you can see the
details of that build now you have built
a container image and pushed it into
container registry we're
can be used with other parts of the
Google cloud build process
[Music]